qu'est-ce que vous à moi tiré professeur
awa a publié tout ça voilà à rendre
publics tous les coups de c ces choses
si vous voulez je pense qu'une
des questions
j'ai dû compliqué pour moi ou difficile
pour moi c'est la discordance qu'il ya
dans les temps que nous vivons vous
vivez dans un temps très instantané la
vérité du jour et je veux dire ça toupet
tous les gens qui sont victimes de d'un
coup d'une même quand je n'aime pas
beaucoup mais qui sont victimes d'un
coup de pression médiatique extrêmes
donc avant qu'on les juge avant qu'on
ait eu le temps de regarder quoi que ce
soit il ya des gens qui supporte pas ça
mais si j'ai un conseil à leur donner
c'est laisser passer un mois 3 mois non
vous verrez plus personne ne s'en
souviendra c'est ça et donc cette
différence dans le temps pour moi elle
est très importante et donc moi je sais
quand je dis quelque chose que je veux
pouvoir le relire un ans 5 ans 10 ans
après une pas avoir honte de moi et donc
ce que j'écris là c'est tout ce que j'ai
dit c'est une des raisons protège je
contrôle ce que je dis je veux pas me
laisser embarquer par à des gens qui
sont hostiles et qui me forcerais mettre
en colère je suis désagréable quand je
suis en colère je suis pas obligé de
l'être il ya très peu de gens qui sont
agréables quand ils sont en colère mais
voilà mais moi je regrette après de
désagréable ça je préfère ne pas l'être
mais ce que je dis je veux pouvoir c'est
j'ai reçu récemment j'avais fait un
rapport qui online commissaire à la
santé en 2002 2003 vous pouvez le lire
je ne dis pas de bêtises je disais il va
arriver une épidémie respiratoires parce
qu'on sait pas les contrôler parce que
l'association de mégapoles faire de
villes de plus de 10 millions
d'habitants avec un milliard de gens qui
prennent l'avion par an ça veut dire
qu'il ya une diffusion extra large et
une laisse et en 2002 donc je veux
pouvoir
ne pas me dire deux choses dont j'aurais
honte et qui serait ridicule terme donc
c'est ce que je fais ça les rats se dit
ça reste un verbatim ça veut dire c'est
mot-à-mot ça que j'ai dit qu'on peut pas
me faire dire ce que savent pas qu'il
vaut mieux que ce soit vous qui écrivez
donc comme ça on sait que c'est vous à
ses bras pas voulons qu après bien
entendu les choses et la connaissance
évolué donc chose qu'on pouvait imaginer
j'essaie tout le temps de faire la
différence entre ce qu'on voit comme
étant rétablie pour l'instant et avec
les outils qu'on a bien sûr est ce que
je peux imaginer où ce que je pense en
différenciant clairement on est pas
tendre un livre d'une manière générale
vous voulez aussi montré dans le livre
que la gestion de la crise a été
pratiquement catastrophique voilà
c'était s'esquisser ce qu'on vous dit
qu'est-ce qu'elle aspects de la crise
besoin de plus déranger la gestion si
vous voulez je moi j'ai essayé de mettre
en garde dès le départ contre le
l'affolement et la perte des réflexes
habituels si vous regardez maintenant en
tête vous choquer mais je vérifiais
s'ajuste voyez sur mon téléphone alors
de voler si vous regardez maintenant
est-ce que vous pensez que l'espérance
de vie et humain a diminué en 2020 en
2021 la réponse est non en france elle a
diminué juste en 2020 je vous dire
pourquoi 2021 elle a repris le rythme
qu'elle avait avant l'espérance de vie
qui avait avant 2010 n'a fait de mal à
baisser en 2020 la bc en 2020 parce que
la gestion si et dans l'est a été
absolument catastrophique elle a été
catastrophique parce qu'on a oublié
c'est pour ça que le sous titre de ça ça
oubliez que la médecine serré médecine
et qu'il ya un artisanat dans la
médecine dans lequel il ne faut jamais
oublier il faut soigner les malades il
faut aller les voir et donc qu'il ya eu
un moment le le politique et
l'information se sont emparés d'une
maladie en dix ans et plus au médecin
s'est plu aux gens à s'en occuper il
faut que vous restiez j'ai des goûts en
leur donnant des consignes qui était et
consignes absolument inappropriés à
cette maladie en particulier attendent
d'être essoufflé ci est une catastrophe
dans cette maladie rare et on sait
maintenant et donc les gens attachés à
la table des retraites aux flics anti
rentrée le première chose qu'ils
essaient en réanimation parce que
personne ne leur avait donné de soins et
donc le soin ça n'est pas un truc du 21e
siècle soit observé c'est un truc qui a
des milliers d'années et donc il faut
soigner les gens et la leçon la plus
pertinente mois que j'ai vu c'est en
afrique que je connais bien l'afrique
subsaharienne et bien c'est un mystère
comme on essaie de bellus idée la
mortalité est la plus faibles du monde
en afrique et en particulier pour moi à
cause de la médecine comme communautaire
c'est à dire que personne n'a été
laissée isoler les gens allaient voir
les maladies leur donner quelque chose
dit complet les médecins des médicaments
traditionnels et retiré la plupart
prennent des antipaludéens et tout ça a
fait que en dépit du fait qu'ils n'ont
pratiquement pas de vaccin qui ne sont
pas vaccinés les biens leur mois de
pelleter la plus belle du monde vous dit
laissons les médecins s'occuper des
baladins ce que vous venez de nous
expliquer c'est le sous titre 1-2 de
votre de votre livre pourquoi la france
n'a pas su développer un vaccin parce
que c'est vrai que c'est ce qu'elle ne
le président de sanofi a dit c'est vrai
il faut le reconnaître un échec par
rapport à la rapidité qu'il fallait
c'est extrêmement dommageable pour la
santé publique et pour nous à l'heure
actuelle sanofi n'est parvenu à
développer qu'un seul vaccin contre la
maladie et est encore en cours d'examen
aux états unis et dans l'union
européenne c'est incroyable que la
france n'ait pas réussi
je ne sais pas jouer moi j'avais suggéré
je crois encore ça que le sanofi aurait
dû développer il ya un vrai savoir faire
chez sanofi dans les adjuvants je pense
qu'ils auraient dû faire comme les
chinois ont fait leur vaccin faire un
chinois un vaccin comme le vaccin de la
grippe c'est à dire un vaccin avec du
virus qui est inactivé et des adjuvants
qui sont des vaccins qui sont un tout
petit peu plus long mais pas tellement à
préparer avec les chaînes en russie
réaliser ce assez rapidement et qui ne
comporte pas les interrogations qu'on
armed utilisant dans une situation
nouvelle des formes de vaccins qui n'ont
jamais été évaluée avant sur cette
échelle donc c'est un choix moi j'aurais
fait le choix de
de faire ça de faire un vaccin atténuer
le même vaccin que la grippe qui est ce
qu'il est qui est pas parfait mais enfin
il y en a aucun de ces vaccins qui sont
parfaits si vous voulez mais qui protège
et au curé protégée en partie des formes
graves les gens qui risquait de faire
des formes graves qui auraient dû être
l'objectif financier alors here on
apprenait la disparition de maurice est
doyer et marc était avec nous hier avec
avec son fils pour lui
elle est décédée suite aux effets
secondaires du vaccin il des sur notre
plateau hier j'aimerais qu'on revient
sur ce moment et que vous nous donniez
votre sentiment là-dessus
elle fait plus vous verrez pas mon essai
je mets la main vous savez pourquoi
c'est ce que j'essaie de montrer en fait
nous revers de médaille du
bénéfice-risque la vie de tous les jours
dans ces cas là je fais pas ci là où ils
vont comprendre bah écoute et voilà il
n'y a pas d'effets secondaires
bien des mois j'attends que ça me faire
engueuler insulté qu'est ce que ça me
manque
alors
est ce que marc drillon là et on l'a vu
sur sur énormément de platon est ce que
vous comprenez ce qu'il avait twitté un
moment voilà sur kaiser qui aurait lui
aurait pris sa femme marc ailleurs
m'écrire là et il m'a envoyé le
certificat de décès de deux de
mauricette est ce que c est ce que c'est
possible ça que ce soit arrivé swann
effets secondaires du vaccin on peut
tuer les les effets secondaires rares
c'est dans les effets secondaires
j'avais expliqué ça une fois il ya des
choses qui sont très simples y compris
même des effets qui sont pas vraiment
des effets secondaires mais des
réactions à au fait qu'on vous fait une
piqûre avait quelque chose dont vous
savez pas trop ce que c'est qu'on va
faire l'effet nocebo les infections dans
les halles dans les effets secondaires
rares c'est une décès était un des
problèmes de la réactivité et de la peur
de cette épidémie c'est que on n'a
finalement pas respecté les règles qu'on
s'était donné jusqu'à maintenant pour
évaluer le vaccin pour évaluer vaccins
et ça fait longtemps qu'il ya des gens
qui auraient bien voulu qu'on les
dédouane de évaluation des vaccins tels
qu'on pense qu'on doit faire c'est à
dire si on doive vacciner est là je
crois qu'on en est à 12 milliards de
personnes qui ont été vaccinées il faut
prendre la mesure pour pouvoir évaluer
et trouver les effets secondaires par
exemple c'est vrai qu'elle est mieux car
dit qu'il est mort subite un de
myocardite chedhomme jeunes c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu et thrombose cérébrale chez
les femmes jeunes qui ont été liés aux
vaccins qui sont pas des événements que
l'on pouvait très facilement observer en
ayant des délais aussi courts et en
ayant aussi peu de gens qui étaient
inclus on ne pouvait pas mesurer non
plus l'efficacité du vaccin rro bout de
4-5 mois en faisant une évaluation des
vaccins pendant six mois c'est
mécaniquement impossible donc il ya eu
un choix politique qui a été pris de
dévaluer partiellement
l'efficacité et la tolérance de ces
vaccins sur des des effets secondaires
parce que on pensait un certain nombre
de gens pensaient que la situation était
tellement catastrophique que on allait
avoir
une baguette magique qui allait résoudre
nos problèmes de cette épidémie qui
allaient exterminer la population de la
terre avec la population de la terre a
continué à grandir population de la
france va continuer à grandir nous on
vient de sortir un travail sur tous les
morts cent pour cent des morts des chu
de nice et de marseille la moyenne d'âge
des morts et 80 ans et ceux qui étaient
plus jeunes que ça des gens qui avaient
des pathologies à côté des cancers
évolutif ou des maladies immuno
déprimante donc c'était pas il n'est pas
arrivé là peste là et donc qu'il fallait
garder son talent il fallait soigner les
gens il fallait se consacrer à soigner
les gens les plus vulnérables il fallait
et il faut vacciner les gens les plus
vulnérables
la durée de protection de ce vaccin dans
la situation actuelle c'est peut-être un
mois et demi pour les formes graves et
donc c'est très peu donc là c'est très
peur - admirer c'est très peu donc tout
ça le fait des prix par la panique si
vous voulez qu'elle notre société est
confrontée 1 par la panique à chaque
fois qu'un événement plutôt que de
prendre le temps de la réflexion de
l'analyser et de faire une analyse a
posteriori pour comprendre ce qui s'est
passé et ce temps n'est plus pris parce
que effectivement
aux sources d'information quand elle
passe par vous montrer
pour pouvoir attirer l'attention sont
très violentes sont très brutal centre
et parce que c'est ce qui attire
l'attention fécond synthétisant plus
beaucoup donc fort là c'est très court
et puis le temps passe et puis nos
démocraties aussi ce mois je me
demandais pendant des années pourquoi ça
fait 25 ans que j'ai essayé de faire
augmenter une manière très très
considérable le nombre de gens qui
peuvent faire médecine en france peuvent
pas faire métier ne les empêche ferme et
ils ont les uns portent des pays du sud
les pauvres les gosses funky en roumanie
salle au portugal pour le faire en
espagne vous prouvez le font pas c'est
ça parce que moi je finis par penser
peut-être avec cynisme mais c'est parce
que il faut huit ans au moins pour faire
un médecin et comme le mandat des gens
ces cinq ans ils s'en foutent ils
verront pas donc au bout d'un moment et
au plus si vous demandez aux partenaires
sociaux est ce que vous avez vraiment
besoin de concurrence oui on non si vous
voyez c'est donc et un moment c'est la
stratégie d'état sur une chose comme ça
c'est une chose qui est extrêmement
importante et qui est une des raisons
pour lesquelles on a tellement problème
on manque terriblement de médecins mais
tout le monde le sait et c'est des
chiffres les chiffres de l' ocde montre
que la france est un des pays qui a le
moins de médecins les pays dos et de
l'eau c'est elle qui ça montre que c'est
nous qui avons le plus excuser moi mais
les médecins vie les médecins de plus de
55 ans c'est nous qui avons le plus de
vies au même ça et heureusement qu'ils
allaient vivre parce que ça il continue
à travailler donc je voulais on a là un
problème de fond qui est que politique
s'est emparé de la médecine pour dire je
marche pas si c'est parce que les études
sont trop chers c'est parce qu'ils
n'aiment pas les médecins ne sais pas ce
qui se passe mais il ya une approche de
la médecine la qui est en train de
changer où on pense qu'on va remplacer
les médecins par des informations de la
direction générale de la santé c'est pas
vrai il faut aller les voir et se
soigner il faudra surveiller il faut les
calmer c'est comme ça qu'on fait sinon
on arrive à ce qui s'est passé c'est à
dire que d'un coup tout le monde va aux
urgences parce qu'il ya plus de médecins
pour vous soigner les urgences explose
ils sont plus capables de gérer les gens
elle renvoie les gens à la maison où ils
passent directement en réanimation et
donc on ne gère pas les choses les
choses se gère pas dans la panique alors
on a vu des images à shanghai objectif
zéro co vide les images chez nous on
fait froid dans le dos on va revoir ces
images le conflit la chanteuse à une
lyre si c'est possible ça si c'est si ça
peut arriver en france que c'est vrai
que c'est on se dit ça avait démarré à
l'époque en chine hélas ce qu'on voit on
se dit est ce que ça peut arriver en
france dans quelques semaines
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que c'est possible ça quand
pourquoi de telles images professeur
moscou pour expliquer nos testeurs qui
dit comment ça c'est que ça se passe
comme ça là bas est vrai ce que ça peut
arriver chez nous d'autant health in
telle situation si vous
comprendrez mieux pourquoi j'ai écrit ce
que j'ai ce que je dis au fur et à
mesure sous les on était face à une
maladie inconnue il ya des gens qui ont
fait des modèles mathématiques pour
expliquer ce qui allait se passer et ce
qui est une grande folie mais vous y
replonger immédiatement où vous pouvez
pas vous en empêcher vous aimez ça que
vous preniez l'avenir s'il vous plaît
j'adore il retomberait 6,6 idée ça va ça
pour ça
c'est donc quand on a commencé les gens
vous ont prédit un certain nombre de
choses qui étaient imprévisibles et donc
une des prévisions et le au début de
l'épidémie ceci a ressemblé à ce que
l'on a habituellement c'est à dire une
courbe en cloche voulez du nombre de cas
face à audard ancelotti a diminué ça
s'arrête c'est la grille si vous voulez
mais et puis simplement un ce virus-là
passe par toute cette famille des
revenus de ces coronavirus mais ce ce
groupe de virus là il est nouveau chez
nous chez l'humain oui et donc on ne
pouvait pas prévoir ce qu'il a fait il
ya des gens qui ont fait la stratégie
zéro covin et 5 0 ça a été au début ça a
marché c'est à dire ça a été la nouvelle
zélande et les îles en général ça
marchait plus facile de biosphère
désigne et puis ça a été la chine qui a
interdit voilà on rentre plus lent sort
plus à chaque fois qu'on attendait
carnelle sauf que ce virus ne fait pas
comme ça et donc en particulier il a une
capacité à générer des ce qu'on a appelé
les variations et que qui si vous
regardez un peu les choses que l'on a
publié les premiers au monde à parler de
l'ariège d'accord on parle ça de juillet
2020 et bien pris et les gens qui
savaient même pas que regarder un génome
devrions faisait pas la région mais
reste en queue
donc le premier point c'est qu'il ya des
variants qui apparaissent dans l'ain qui
est arrivé chez nous l'été alors que la
prod le premier épisode était fini au
printemps il arrive l'été et puis le
premier on voit très bien il arrive de
il arrive du maghreb par bateau mais on
a de la chance il était enfin
d'évolution et donc ils dépassent très
très peu de la zone de marseille et
disparaissent et puis il y en a un autre
dont on y arrive juste après dont on
sait maintenant qui vient d'espagne qui
va faire une grande partie de l'europe
on ne sait pas pourquoi il va pas de
s'imposer en france et pis y en a un
autre qu'on appelle marseille 4 ça c'est
bien made in france qui a été fait ça
m'a vraiment maintenant les données dans
l'élevage de vision français
d'eure-et-loir d'accord et qui lui va
tuer plus que tous les autres donc on a
là deux choses 1 on a des variants 2 on
a des sources animal ce une zoonose et
c'est un virus qui fait des allers
retours entre les animaux et les humains
c'est une des raisons pour lequel dès ce
moment-là on sait que ça n'est pas un
objectif possible de penser qu'on va
éradiquer cette maladie c'est pas
possible elle va changer il faut
apprendre à la traiter et où vous voulez
mais qu'elle sera toujours là voilà elle
va rester là voilà sous une forme qui
pour différentes elle va rester là et
donc comme elles changent mais assis et
que les virus mutent en permanence
et bien quand vous vous faites des
vaccins ces bons points de vue qui sont
trop ciblée sur une seule zone c'est
très facile pour le virus d'introduire
une mutation qui va assez sa place avec
le rubicon des mutations qui vont
échapper aux défenses immunitaires soit
que vous avez eu naturellement la
maladie avant donc vous pouvez en faire
deux on peut bien me faire deux au micro
on voit des avec le le 1 et 2 2 et bien
ce jour vous pouvez faire le delta est
le micro le au micron est donc bien
entendu les vaccins sont pas plus
efficaces que l'infection naturelle il
n'ya pas de cadre dans lequel les
vaccins marche mieux que l'infection
naturelle donc voilà il faut apprendre à
lire à 20 qu'il faut apprendre à
protéger les gens qui sont les plus
fragiles parce qu'on sait que c'est eux
qui on risque de mourir il faut le
prendre le plus précocement possible
et voilà l'hypothèse la plus plausible
moi je ne fais pas de de science fiction
sur l'hypothèse la plus plausible c'est
que ça devienne quelque chose qui
ressemble à la glisse un petit à petit
devienne saisonniers et qui est certaine
mortalité pas négligeable c'est un art
alité hivernale voilà si ça devient si
c'est pendant la saison d'hiver c'est
tous les virus respiratoires s'emparant
une jarre a casté vous avez une question
de proportions recevait le loyer qui est
le mari de s'être il a dit que le
dossier copie de maths a été classé
secret défense alors on sait ce que ça
veut dire si c'est vrai qu'on n'aura pas
accès aux données avancées pas 20 ou 30
ans est-ce que c'est d'abord est ce que
c'est vrai et qu'est ce que ça veut dire
heureux
je croyais comme vous et je ne crois
plus parce que j'ai posé la question
voilà directement aux gens qui font
une investigation je me demande si c'est
un lien avec le fait que j'ai été
harcelée par miss à la santé mais ils
font l'investigation pour la cour de
justice de la république qui voulait
savoir si on va il va y avoir un procès
pour pour madame +1 et pour monsieur
virant et donc j'aurais posé la question
et m'ont dit non nous dans le cadre de
cette enquête on peut avoir accès sous
la supervision d'un préfet hors-cadre
motivé pour le regarder c'est à dire que
l'on n'utilise que ce qui est destiné à
l'anc est donc c'est accessible s'il ya
une enquête de sept mètres l'ensemble de
données c'est accessible oui géraldine
mais je ne savais pas répondu une bêtise
j'aurais répondu spontanément se
respecte pas dépendre oui professeurs
nous on est des croyants vous êtes un
sachant et c'est vrai que vous avez
raison vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
pendant deux ans on a été pris dans une
sorte de tsunami de tourbillon médiatico
sanitaires et pendant ces deux ans on a
eu ce qu'on a appelé ici et d'ailleurs
partout la vague anti anti vax alors
anti pacs pas anti vaccination anti ce
vaccin même vaccin finder est en fait
moi je voulais savoir si il ya une
métastase de cette vague anti mac ça a
été la seleyre complotistes et moi je
vais savoir qu'est ce que vous en
pensiez quand on nous a dit par exemple
que le vaccin parce qu'en fait que tout
ça avait été inventée que ce vaccin
avait été inventé pour juste enrichir
big pharma que finalement voilà on nous
avait mis des puces qu'on voulait nous
manipuler qu'on voulait nous supprimer
qu'on voulait nous épier qu'est ce que
vous avez pensé de tout ce tourbillon
complotistes si vous
encore une fois je pense convient
d'avoir une société qui est très
nerveuse dans tous les sens je ne trouve
pas du tout
qui a une hyperréactivité qui est bien
entendu augmenter par là par nos modes
de communication
et que à la fois j'ai trouvé
disproportionnée cette croyance que pour
une maladie virale respiratoires dus à
un virus à arn on allait trouver une
baguette magique qui allait arrêter tous
et il y avait une espèce de rêve qui
monte est là comme ça ce cauchemar va
s'arrêter avant le vaccin est le
cauchemar va s'arrêter et donc il y a ça
c'était un côté de l'autre côté il ya
des gens qui disaient qu'ils voient et
moi je sûr je le juge je suis et j'ai
écrit un livre seul vaccin je vous
recommande c'est bien longtemps en
disant qu'il fallait essayer d'être
intelligent avec le vaccin ce qui est
très compliqué parce que les vaccins
ça n'est pas du soin c'est on vous
injecte quelque chose alors que vous
n'êtes pas malade et que ça depuis le
début glissant la vaccination ça pose un
problème qui est compliqué c'est à dire
est-ce que qu'elle est pourquoi est-ce
qu'on fait ça est ce que je vais
vraiment 1-1 bénéfice est ce qu'il y a
plus de bénéfices pour moi que dans le
site une vraie question mais ça modifie
notre adn par exemple ce vaccin comme
disait ça pas qu'on sache non pas qu'on
sache qu'on ce qu'ont les éléments qu'on
a sur le virus qui a été publié c'est
que sur virus à arn mais c'est très
compliqué
il ya des choix une chose qui alimente
les complotistes et de mentir et donc
qu'il ya des gens qui pour le bien des
gens leur ment et il s'en rende compte
voilà et quand ils se sont rendu compte
qu'on leur mente et dire qu'on leur
disait pas la vérité ou que les gens qui
étaient censés être des sachants dedans
n'était pas moi je me rappelle par
exemple la société de pathologie de
langue française a fait une grande des
questions réponses en dix ans la reine
ne pas se transformer en adn et on sait
depuis 89 qu'il ya tous les enzymes qui
font que la reine peut être intégré dans
l'air la haine peut être intégré dans
l'adn et il ya un papier très beau
copier fait par une très bonne équipe
qui monte de l'intégration d'une partie
du virus lui-même pas les vaccins mais
du virus lui-même à l'intérieur des
cellules donc c'est des choses qui sont
rarissimes mais qui ne sont pas ça n'est
pas impossible
scientifiquement mais ça veut pas dire
que ce soit un phénomène fréquent ça ne
veut pas dire que ça existe pour le
vaccin mais il ya une vraie question qui
est voyez d'abord qui s'est posée que
moi j'ai vécu dans le plus profond d'eux
mêmes c'est qui a le droit de dire est
ce que comme scientifique vous avez le
droit de dire vous directement sans être
médiée par le politique ou par le
journalisme est une vraie question est
est ce qu'on doit le dire parce que de
le dire s'est introduit un doute mais le
doute qu'on introduit si on m'en est
beaucoup plus grave beaucoup plus long
et on voit ça dans beaucoup de pays en
particulier en afrique reculer la
vaccination qui n'était pas remise en
cause maintenant à cause du fait qu' on
a imposé une vaccination qui dont les
effets sur une grande partie de la
population n'est pas très grand en
disant écoutez c'est merveilleux il ya
aucun problème et y en aura aucun accord
donc il faut faire attention à garder un
discours balancer mais c'est difficile
dans les médias et c'est difficile avec
les politiques qui sont comme les médias
en afrique on nous a dit aussi que les
gens et vous allez poser comme un
téléphone a bien être professeur si tu
veux rencontrer pour vous ou tu regardes
du label ni gilbert des prix professeurs
on voit derrière cyril la mention
accusations d c'est interdit vous avez
été accusé par certains médias qui ont
rendu leur enquête publique d'avoir fait
des essais interdit notamment contre la
tuberculose la question aller simple
avez vous oui ou non procéder à des
recherches et des essais interdite
elles n'ont pas du tout non mais c'était
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que vous
savez chaque fois que j'ai l'accusation
ou à chaque fois que je le dis quelque
chose qu'on peut encore dit finalement
les gens finissent par dire oui mais et
on rajoute une tranche alors je peux
vous dire l'agencé agence du médicament
a indiqué à parce qu'il ya un rapport
qui est sorti le 27 avril et a indiqué
saisir le procureur de la république à
ce sujet oui elle avait déjà alors je
vous dirais le cedis régulièrement et il
se passe pour l'instant il se passe
jamais rien reste à dire que la dernière
fois c'était le 5 novembre il y avait
une légère hausse une lettre qui était
extrêmement toxique de d2 ministre de la
santé d'université en disant monsieur
raoul tu fais des essais et légaux sur
la tuberculose s'est confirmée par 100
voix de confirmation par une enquête
interne de du directeur de la séance
publique comme ça que les autres en se
basant sur le fait que avait été publiée
dans mediapart ce qui est tout à fait
illégal le dossier d'un malade c'est
totalement illégal ils ont délégué
dix personnes sont chez brasles depuis
l'époque est à la fin sur la tuberculose
chez eux mais on dit pas dedans on lui
dit le diplomate 15 et 46 ont été
identifiés doré chez bien dans le
premier quart c'est que j'étais
désagréable avec eux ce qui est vrai
d'ailleurs parce que je trouvais que
c'était désagréable desquels les choses
pareilles donc je vous le dire on verra
bien voyez est globalement il faut pas
tout mélanger c'est à dire que tout ce
qui s'est passé pour vous dire la vérité
la première chose qui nous reprochent ce
qui est la plus intéressante de tout
c'est une étude qui est des fêtes par dd
écouvillon qui ont été pris chez les
enfants qui avaient des diarrhées et
qu'il ya des enfants qui n'avaient pas
de diarrhée chez qui on va demander aux
parents ce qu'on peut faire un
écouvillon pouvoir la différence
d'accord y est la question que vous
posez sur l'échiquier l'art si vous
n'avez pas de contrôle total des
contrôles vous savez pas ce que c'est
cette étude a été lancée avant même que
les choix existe dans leur poche à
douille n'a été fait en 2009 yayi a été
officiellement créé et bien entendu
pratiquement bien après en 2010 elle a
été réalisée dans le grand d'associer de
notre directeur
l'hôpital parce que moi j'ai jamais reçu
d'enfants dans le service qui est dirigé
par le président de la commission
médicale d'établissement qui s'appelle
jean luc jousse et 8 y en a près la
responsabilité et le promoteur c'est
l'assistance publique donc je ne vois
pas ce que j'ai à voir avec ça et c'est
le conseil scientifique de l'assistance
lui qui l'a validé d'accord et 138 et
rétrospectivement validé par le comité
d'éthique dirigée par le doyen à la
faculté de médecine moi ce que j'ai fait
c'est j'ai fait de la prée cr sur
découvrions comment voyez donc moi je
veux bien que le broker la république
pas le problème pour le vendre pour lui
expliquer je sais pas j'ai pas de
problème avec ça donc il faut bien voir
quand ces machines de guerre se met en
place mais huit inspecteurs c'est un
plaisir mais le gars se lit la tête des
scènes de légionnaires c8 qui sont là
depuis plus de trois ans resté chez
autrement a émis mais on en a encore
toutes les semaines on a un truc inouï
ce qui nous font mais c'est intéressant
par les logis ces gens là hein
au logis ces jours là c'est fou ça vous
est donc moi je n'ai pas de problème
avec la justice le beh je peux vous le
dire 1 nous avons porté plainte contre
médiapart de nous allons porter plainte
contre le directeur de l'assistance
publique je peux vous dire c'est vrai ça
ça va passer devant la justice pour de
bon la plupart de ceux qu'on appelle les
anti vaccins ne sont pas satisfaits de
la réalisation d' emmanuel macron parce
qu'ils ont peur qu'on les prive de leur
liberté est ce que vous pensez qu'il ya
un candidat qui aurait proposé une
meilleure gestion du coc vide vous
saurez inchangé saiss et pas trop écouté
j'ai je me suis exprimé sur ce point de
vue là on a essayé de me faire
m'exprimer sur un point ou un autre mais
je le dis jamais pour qu'ils jouent
depuis j'ai pas de légitimité pour dire
aux gens ce qu'ils doivent voter mais
globalement je moi je vois une chose
dans mon expérience je regrette qu'elle
soit si long parce que je voudrais bien
qu'elle ait 20 ans 2 mois mais en tout
cas ce que j'ai vu d'abord c'est pas
nécessairement ceux pour qui j'ai voté
dernière qui ont été élues ni ceux pour
qui j'ai voté qui ont été élus qui ont
fait le meilleur travail donc moi je
sais pas plus près dire ça qu'il ya une
chose que j'ai vu c'est quand même ce
qui est très important c'est le casting
si un président de la république c'est
une chose tous obnubilés par ça mais si
vous mettez des gens qui ne sont pas
compétents ou qui sont des gens qui ont
de l'amertume contre le propre corps
social qui sont censés représenter et
gérer vous avez des problèmes donc ce
qui est important c'est qu'ils vous
mettez là la barre directement parce que
l'idée que le président de la république
c'est l'équipe téléguidé depuis l'elysée
est un fait normal c'est pas vrai il
faut des gens qui s'occupent donc s'il y
a un très bon ministre la santé mon dieu
il réfléchira il s'appuiera sur tous les
savoirs du pays et pas dans une position
d'affrontement qui n'est pas raisonnable
et puis je vous rappelle enfin je ne
veux pas faire honte à la modestie qui
en a vu d'autres mais enfin il ya
personne qui a publié en maladies
infectieuses comme moi dans le monde
dont on peut pas être en hausse en six
mois le dire ils affrontent avec moi et
l'humidité ici
venu heures c'est vrai oui non moi j'ai
une question à vous poser professeurs
commencent à sec depuis deux ans depuis
2020 on vit avec des variants les deltas
delta 2 au micron il ya eu tout le temps
des variantes ou les deux trois quatre
mois on a toutes envie qu avec ça les
enfants avec le masque et puis depuis
janvier février il ya l'ukraine qui
arrive et il ya les exposants arrivent
et les variants ça il en dit en estimant
tranquille monde se serre la main on
revit quand max au club med ça
m'intrigue mois de safia quoi la radio
j'entends pu parler de deux variants
pourquoi j'entends pu parler à la télé
pour ce n'est pas une question à tout le
monde se serre la main pourquoi tout le
monde veut faire la bise donc est ce
qu'on a vraiment fini avec le covin ou
est-ce que ça va revenir parce que c'est
dans le monde entier non monde entier
c'est pareil aussi c'est sûr intrigué
mois là le respect du variant qui nous
laisse tranquille pour l'instant et qui
reviendra peut-être alors
il ya des travaux qui sont qui sont un
peu complexe mais moi je charrie plus
j'arrive à analyser ce qui se passe à
marseille pour là je sais pas donc tous
les variants le pire des variants qu'on
ait eue en terme de mortalité c'est ce
qu'on appelle marseille 4 ce qui venait
dé et des visons d'élevage français ils
n'ont pas tous la même mortalité ils
n'ont pas tous la même sévérité et puis
je pense encore une fois que le lh
l'affolement la panique qui a pris les
gens au départ en particulier ici il ya
eu un tribut à ce pays qui a été payé en
2001 qui est considérable ici et dans
l'est
les choses ont changé je vous rappel
c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit ça moi je
me suis fait engueuler par le directeur
de la rs qui est au dessus de nous
parce qu'on faisait pas ce qu'on faisait
des tests et on dit maintenant des mois
je le fais ma direction depuis quarante
ans maintenant pas grave je le sais bien
que pour faire le site magnifique c'est
ce qu'il faut faire un diagnostic d'un
test les n'en faut pas faire de tests
non comme pour rappeler ont freiné que
parce qu'on était les seuls compris la
moitié des gens qui venaient en tgv à
marseille vallée pour se faire tester
dans le parisien donc il faut voir
qu'ici il y avait aucun test on faisait
rien encore donc c'est pas une manière
de traiter les choses il faut
s'organiser et c'est pour ça que je
disais ça ressemble beaucoup à
juin 40 c'est parce que les gens ont
démissionné avant de commencer et c'est
pas comme ça la médecine n'est pas comme
ça là la lutte contre les épidémies
c'est pas comme ça il faut tout le monde
se retrousse les manches et c'est de
faire ce qu'il peut avec ce qu'il a et
je peux vous dire parce que je les dis
dans le conseil scientifique dit
officiellement on peut pas faire de tête
parce qu'on n'a pas les moyens et il y
avait le plus gros laboratoire
vétérinaire qui a écrit à la fois à moi
et à delfraissy pour leur dire j'ai de
quoi faire trente mille tests si vous
voulez évoluer l'envoyer - envoyez moi
et le conseil scientifique n'a jamais
répondu donc ça veut dire que les gens
disent on peut pas faire les tests qui
cherchait pas à les faire nous on a
acheté des machines supplémentaires on a
fait importer des choses pour pouvoir
faire face aux besoins c'est à laisser
le besoin kid est permise ce que l'on
doit faire et c'est pas de dire on peut
rien faire
on a des questions sur les twitter qui
sont arrivés que pense-t-il des
soignants suspendu tient simple c'est
pas mal c'est une bonne question doit
populaire est une bonne question je
réponds ce que c'est pas raisonnable ça
on est d'accord alors n'est ce pas
raisonnable ça va on dit c'est un vaccin
d'accord maintenant mon fric c'est pas
vrai que ça empêche la maladie il ya
autant nous on en a on regarde y'a
autant la proportion de positif chez
nous chez vacciner non vaccinés hammam
peut-être ça protège des formes graves
chez les gens qui sont vulnérables mais
on et deuxièmement ça n'empêche pas la
contagiosité donc on veut pas dire que
les gens qui sont
visibles s'aigrissent titiste un ami
bonjour monsieur pensez vous que le
courrier d'un virus et finito il nous en
a parlé le point où il y en a il va la
voir aller on allait devoir vivre avec 1
6 qui a eu dix questions suivantes
méforme s'il vous plaît merci
merci merci merci bonjour professeur est
ce que la cause de ce virus est connue
ou toujours pas ça c'est une très bonne
question site forte x om 55 on voit à
peu près on voit à peu près ce qui se
passe
si vous voulez je vous conseille un des
types qui indé qui était déjà un des
meilleurs spécialistes des coronavirus
au plan fondamental qui s'appelle bruno
canard qui a fait une magnifique
conférence chez nous pour expliquer ce
qu'on savait et lui il a continué après
le premier sarce c'est pas comme les
journaux de parler de ça pendant quinze
jours et puis on pas faire autre chose
il n'a pas cessé de travailler sur le
coup on à virus donc donc ce qu'on voit
c'est que ce groupe ii coronavirus et un
groupe qu'on voit dans pratiquement tous
les animaux d'accord donc c'est juste
une question de temps peut savoir de
quand ils feront passer
l'humain de plomb ils vont pas le placer
en particulier où on voit bien
maintenant par les reconstructions qu'on
fait ça les rend si on regarde d'où
viennent les séquences des gènes et bien
on voit que ça vient des chauves-souris
chiens et chauves souris sont un
réservoir absolument hallucinant
c'est pas tellement de maladie les
chauves souris vivent comme nous l ont
des villes de chauves souris dans une
grotte vous pas voir un million de
chauves-souris qui soit à se frotter les
unes les autres ah ah et donc quand vous
avez
des convictions écolos souris de faire
des maladies contagieuses c'est leur vie
et donc si vous regardez je tiens je
vais vous faire peur thunder fait pour
vous ça me permettra si vous regardez
chez les animaux sauvages dont je
travaille avec les gens du gabon qui
avait fait qu'ils avaient commencé à
travailler sur le virus de la faune
sauvage et vous êtes très impressionné
si vous regardez la faune sauvage il y à
tout un groupe de virus qui sont les
mêmes virus extrêmement proche de virus
de la rougeole il ya un groupe de virus
qui sont extrêmement proches du virus
des oreillons d'accord très très proches
ça veut dire que vous si vous arrêtez la
protection par les oreillons et là où je
ne pourrais pas dire que je suis anti
mac
de fait et bien il est bien possible que
ça réémerge à partir d'un foyer animal
doux que c'est probablement partie au
départ d'accord donc voilà ça existe les
animaux sont et la capacité des humains
à inventer un virus à côté des milliards
de chauves souris si vous vous laissez
pas raisonnable d'autant qu'on connaît
pas vraiment les facteurs de virulence
on sait pas ce qui les rend plus
virulents et je vais même vous dire plus
si on avait construit un corot navios
avec ce qu'on sait maintenant on
n'aurait pas fait ça parce que on voit
que l'adaptation à l'homme passe par la
destruction d'un certain nombre de gènes
qui ne lui sont pas nécessaires pour
donner des épidémies chez l'homme et
donc ça veut dire que son adaptation et
récente alors qu'elle vient d'arriver et
qu'elle vient d'ailleurs et donc c'est
très
c'est un virus qui est en train de
s'adapter à l'homme petit à petit de se
changer et les variants ou convois sont
des variants il ya des mutations qu'on
voit se répéter dans les différents
coins du monde au fur et à mesure de son
adaptation à l'homme
anissa vous êtes de marseille non oui je
suis de marseille
vous avez une question est ce que c'est
vous qui a dans le clip de l'algérino 2
on m'a dit ça m'a fait beaucoup voilà
c'est un sosie monsieur
le professeur didier raoult d'abord été
avec nous car des deux guerres gobbi des
notes et c'est toujours un bonheur de
vous écouter professeurs ou vraiment on
apprend plein de choses vous nous fait
parfois peur vous nous rassurer souvent
mais c'est vrai que c'est un bonheur de
vous avoir esseyric merci de répondre et
vu professeur awa répondre aux questions
voilà la leçon langue de bois et c'est
incroyable voilà je voulais le dire
merci vraiment à vous et vous savez que
c'est d'avoir le bienvenu sur notre
plateau on est on est vraiment on est on
est fan de vous on vous adore ici et
vous revenez quand vous voulez on
attendra ensemble le nouveau ministre de
la santé on va voir ça va être on s'est
dit tout à l'heure mais il ya un truc
tout à l'heure si vous pour vous c'est
il faudrait un dacquois un homme un
homme politique ou un médecin ou un mois
je pense que le reste si on doit appeler
des gens la société 6 il s'y est pas des
politiques il faut des stars mais les
stars viendront pas fait pas d'illusion
on sait pas on n'est plus à l'époque de
de gaulle où ils pouvaient aller
chercher malraux ils pouvaient aller
chercher c'est fini donc la société
civile si c'est pour prendre des gens
qui n'ont pas eu beaucoup de succès dans
leur métier si vous voulez c'est
finalement ils sont jaloux de nous ils
nous détestent parce que on les prenait
pour pour des moins que rien quand il
était dans les mêmes sites que nous
foyer et d'un coup ils sont au dessus et
c'est une mauvaise idée c'est ce que les
politiques sont pas en rivalité avec
nous ils sont en rivalité avec les
autres politiques donc ce problème là de
la société civile de pas prendre ou vous
arrivez à prendre des stars dans la
société civile ou bien alors il faut
mieux prendre des politiques politiques
qui font la part des choses entre la
jalousie des uns le sentiment de
frustration des autres sur mac on vous
propose d'être remise à santés
certainement
c'est qu'on n'est certainement pas on
était c'est vrai oui mais vous c'est la
première fois qu'on m'en a parlé je vous
étiez pas grand un gars je pense que le
professeur a ou situe certainement pas
c'est que c'est certainement pas je
l'ignoré c'est vrai voilà merci
professeur vous revenez quand vous
[Applaudissements]